[Music]
me that
is
and to the translator names
uh that that is my name in hanja I'm not
sure how it sounds in Korean but I'm
guessing uh the pronunciation is a bit
different I'm not a complicated person
so these emojis pretty much cover who I
am as a person I also have a day job
with Shopify as a senior front-end
developer because I like being able to
pay my rent and stuff
um
so today's talk is focused on CSS
because if your content is going to be
rendered by a browser engine then your
main mode of communication with the
browser for styling content has to be
CSS Now browser engines today are much
more capable than before and they can
lay out content much better than before
so it is in our best interest as web
developers to know how to make full use
of the browser's web layout capabilities
now a major issue with web content is
that your users could be using a screen
as small as a smart watch face or as
large as a 70 inch HDTV and you as the
developer or the designer or the Creator
you can't control this
which means that the way that we think
about designing layouts on the web
cannot be like anything else that is
fixed it is a different mental model and
the tools that we use must suit this
fluid interactive medium but luckily for
us now that flexbox and grid are well
supported across all the major browsers
our toolbox has been greatly upgraded
because both these layout models were
introduced after the web had evolved
into more than just a document viewer
they were built to handle application
interfaces which would be viewed across
many different screen sizes now
admittedly flexbox had a relatively
Rocky rollout as browsers implemented
experimental versions of the syntax B4
the specification had been nailed down
but by 2015 the major browsers had
updated to use the latest spec and the
implementation was very stable
so the browser vendors and specification
authors they learned from the flexbox
rollout and developed grid behind the
feature flag instead of using vendor
prefixes so grid was rolled out in a
very coordinated manner in 2017 with the
four major browsers getting it in March
and by October even Edge and Samsung
internet got it
so when we fast forward today 2022 the
percentage of Internet users surfing the
web with browsers that support flexbox
and grit is overwhelmingly High way past
98 so browser support is no longer a
valid argument for why adoption rates I
feel are lower than expected honestly
flexbox is everywhere because it has
become the go-to for web layouts I've
seen my thousandth how to center
something vertically with flexbox
articles so I'm not surprised that it's
so common today but even though this
survey is a relatively small about 8 000
developers it's still prompted me to
wonder why the grid usage numbers are
not as high as I expected now among the
13 links I have in my bookmarks bar I
could only find grid usage in codepen
Discord inbox and Spotify and only
Spotify really Embrace grid as a page
layout tool they even use named grid
areas
JavaScript was introduced in 95. and a
few years later the concept of Ajax
which stands for asynchronous JavaScript
and XML started to take off because it
allowed content to be updated
dynamically without reloading the entire
page and this is what single page
applications or spas are built upon
that's the concept but the term single
page feels very misleading because the
single page of a book doesn't feel very
large but if you think about a lot of
the Spas out there today it's more like
a page the size of this room so it's
like Spa
and with this increase in scale and
hence complexity the organization of
code becomes a lot more crucial so we
turn to Frameworks because Frameworks
can help provide structure but with
Frameworks there are some restrictions
on how to do things so maybe that's
another reason why grid is not so common
but first let's do a quick run through
of how grit works and how to use it very
similar to flexbox it involves apparent
child relationship between a container
and its immediate children so if you
apply grid properties on the container
you will affect your individual grid
children and the grid children
themselves have an awareness of their
siblings
now the bare minimum to start using grid
as a layout tool is to set display to
grid and then you define some columns so
for example
two columns three columns you
theoretically don't even need to be
explicit about the rows unless you want
to because the row height will naturally
be what the content is now if your grid
needs to be a little bit more
complicated grid comes with a lot of
helpful functions and properties to keep
your code neat so for example the grid
property is a very straightforward way
for you to introduce spaces between your
grid items there are also things like
the repeat function that can help you
dry out your code for example if I don't
want to type that four times
I can do something like this because it
repeats patterns
um another
helpful feature would be keywords for
example if we use autofit in combination
with another function like the min max
function
I see
um
you can actually do
responsive design without media queries
so if this is something that fits your
use case you don't actually have to do
media queries to do something like this
with the help of these functions
but another particularly useful feature
which I'm a big fan of is named grid
areas which you might have noticed in
the Spotify screenshot earlier so after
you've set up your rows and your columns
you can actually name specific areas of
the grid you can assign them names the
syntax is quite visual so the structure
of the grid template areas property is a
reflection of your grid so each of these
three lines corresponds to three rows on
your layout and each of the values
within the lines are the two columns so
I tend to make use of this for designs
that need to break at multiple
breakpoints because then all your
changes can be isolated on the parent
container so what you do is that you can
assign your items to specific areas like
SSI the m is contents and you don't have
to touch it anymore so let's say I uh I
don't I want more columns I want to add
column to this layout so let's let's
change some things around
maybe make that 200 so now I have a
three column grid and I need to move
some stuff around right so how about
let's make the header
full with
the side
okay
I
spell wrongly the
okay it's come on
so what this what this shows is that
if you have many different layouts that
you need to have at different
breakpoints you can isolate them all on
the parent container because this is
very simple there are only four grid
items but let's say you have a more
complicated layout maybe you have 20
items
you don't want to have to write media
queries like four media queries for each
of these items it becomes very hard to
maintain so I feel that this is pretty
helpful for keeping the code very neat
and very easy to manage moving forward
but naming grid areas is actually an
optional property I just find it useful
the regular way of placing items is to
Define its grid row and grid column
properties so I'm going to try turning
on the grid inspector so you can see uh
all so I'm using Firefox but all the
browsers like Chrome and Safari all have
this overlay so what you can do is you
inspect the element and you can turn on
this grid overlay and it will show you
grid numbers
so my image starts from column number
one it spans two columns my headline
starts from column number two and it
spans until column number four so that's
how you place items right and an
advantage of something like this is that
it makes overlapping design much more
controllable than any other methods like
if you try absolute positioning
transforms negative margins it's very
hard to control especially across
different different sizes but the code I
have set up here I have the middle
column where the image and the header is
overlapped to be always 300 pixels so
what happens at different widths is that
I have a controlled overlap I feel that
what this does is that it makes the
lay out a lot more resilient at the very
extreme risk like at the largest and at
the smallest width it's a lot more
resilient with less code
so
there's a lot more to grit than I just
explained but this is already sufficient
for a very large range of ux cases and
the major difference in building layouts
with grid versus other layout models is
that CSS grid layouts are led by the
container so you implement your layout
using a big picture view of your entire
grid and then you place the items on the
grid but the other layout models are
focused on the item so you have to size
and you position your item individually
and so it's it's very different from
what a lot of folks are used to so maybe
that's also a contributing factor to why
grid is not as widespread that being
said it's not like you have to use grit
for everything no grid is just one more
additional tool that you can use flex
floats are actually still great and
relevant for floating content okay and
flexbox is great for handling free space
in your layout and grid is perfect when
you need structured rows and columns
but as an application grows bigger and
has more features more components and
more pages you end up having to adopt
some sort of a design system or develop
some sort of design guidelines to
maintain consistency across the
application so often you have a grid
system and a common pattern for grid
systems in front-end libraries like
bootstrap is you generate all the
classes that you need for all the with
potential risk that you have for the
sizing of each item in your grid so this
is not even the full the full is I don't
know four thousand lines right and to
migrate from floats to flexbox is
actually not that drastic a refactor
because your sizing still happens on the
item but to migrate to grid is a lot
more complicated
so for the sake of discussion we'll
simplify it we'll have assume that we
have the luxury of implementing a new
design system no refactoring and we want
to build out the grid system for that so
let's say your designer hands you these
specs that your designers like build me
this grid with your code your CSS or
whatever
there are many different approaches you
can take to write the CSS to implement
this Grid in a JavaScript powered
application so we'll go through a couple
of these examples to give you an idea
I'm using react in the examples but the
ideas are transferable to other
Frameworks as well so one option is to
just write the CSS so most applications
have a global style sheet you can put
yours you can put the grid Styles there
the rationale is that because this grid
is meant to inform where everything on
your application would sit it can live
in the global style Street gets loaded
everywhere and so you would if I use
something like a Min width
focused breakpoints it will look like
that you start off with four and then
you bump up as in in each breakpoint as
you require
and then your item placement code where
you want your items to be can go into
the component itself
so if they're common placement patterns
that recurve very often in your design
you as the person in charge of the front
end component Library you can have
pre-written styles optional but not
necessary so you can do something like
this pre-written Styles and then the
people who use your system can use these
Styles or they can write their own so if
you're very custom placement the code
would go into your component specific
styles
another approach would be if you have
you could create container and item
components so this means that your grid
code is not loaded in the global style
sheet but it's tied to these components
so if you want to use it you have to
call these components so the setup is
you want to create a column component a
grid component and then these components
are very lightweight they're thin
components they don't do a lot because
all they need to do is be a grid right
so you have things like okay custom
class names you can modify the element
tag because honestly
I know Ria defaults to div but there are
a lot more better HTML tags out there so
like please use them and but in general
these are very lightweight so not a lot
of lines and they're not they don't
restrict you from doing custom things
because all they need to do is be a grid
so the Styles would end up being the
same as in option one because uh but if
you're using something like this you
probably use something like CSS module
so you're naming convention for the
classes can be a bit more casual because
option one had to use bam for for the
classes but with something like CSS
modules you know you can worry less
about the class names and then your
custom code can go into your component
styles
uh
well I'll I will be upfront about this I
am not the biggest fan of how Tailwind
does CSS the major issue I have with
Tailwind is that
it sees the Cascade as a problem to be
solved rather than an attribute to be
embraced
but if you use Tailwind the way it was
intended the Cascade is almost negated
it's gone
but it's called cascading style sheets c
s s for a version so my suggestion is
for them to Rebrand to Tailwind SS just
cut out the sea that being said I'm not
overly stubborn about this if my job
needs me to write Tailwind I can still
do it the way it was intended because
capitalism
but for now I accept the reality that
there are quite a number of teams that
use Tailwind CSS in their applications
and it's working very well for them so
that's great so if those teams want to
use CSS Grid in their application it's
totally doable because Tailwind has
exposed almost every API for you to
modify the default config to suit your
custom specs so the grid specification
that we saw earlier can be set up
something like this it's a little bit
more complicated but yes you can do it
all right
and then you would have to apply these
classes to your components accordingly
so maybe there's some way to make it
less
ugly but this is the most basic version
and it will be able to achieve the exact
same result as the previous two options
so okay this is the butt does it work so
all the code that I showed you is not
fake code it's a real code because I I
tested it um so it kind of it works
uh let's inspect just to show you that
I'm not bullshitting
um
layout
so we can see
that all the approaches that I discussed
um
like grid areas grid template rows
it will work for a very I would say
sometimes your designers will tell you
things right like I want something to
spend five columns or like seven columns
and it's not even an even number but you
can you can do this relatively
straightforwardly using grid and the the
thing is that even the Tailwind example
that I kind of made fun a little bit of
it looks exactly the same the only thing
is you probably won't be able to use the
named grit areas but the point the point
of this example is to show that
all three approaches can achieve exactly
the same result right which brings me to
my next point
we cover only three options but there
are a lot more possible approaches to
implement the grid that we just talked
about
is any of these one approaches the best
are they the correct one I cannot answer
that question because you can't answer
that question without taking into
account the context in which your code
is going to be used technically as I've
shown every approach does the job
perfectly
so usually the the difficulty in
technical implementation is lower
then when you need to consider things
around code organization maintainability
and developer experience especially for
larger teams because every organization
is different some applications have
individual teams in charge of specific
components other team other
organizations could have a few front-end
Specialists maintaining a component
Library used by everybody so the
permutations are endless and Company
culture also varies between
organizations right in some teams
Engineers have a lot of autonomy they
can make decisions they can decide I
want to use this I want to use that in
others
it's a bit more top down so sometimes a
director who used to code will come in
and tell the team you must use x
technology because I like it
such things are out of your control and
that's okay
but if you do get the chance to
influence technical decisions I find
that asking the following questions can
help you make a more informed choice
that benefits the team in the long term
for example what are the preferred
Technologies used in your organization
if any usually there is one it's public
knowledge that Shopify is a Ruby on
Rails shop so it's not like we refuse to
use anything else there are projects
that don't use Ruby on Rails but we do
need a good reason to deviate from the
stack so from a CSS perspective because
we use rails this is going to impact
where my my CSS code lives it will
impact whether you use a process
preprocessor or not how your selectors
look like how much control over the
mockup you have and so on
the size and structure of your
application will also have a significant
impact on how it's organized and how
your final CSS will look like and live
how flexible does your design system
need to be because the more flexible it
is the more complicated your code might
end up becoming because you have to
cater for more use cases so this is
where having a closer relationship with
the design team can help because even
though a design system starts out from
the design team is like a deliverable
from the design team the success of the
design system hinges on the code
reflecting what was originally intended
is are there a lot of new developers
contributing to your Project's code
and what's the documentation culture
like because these two are related
because if they're constantly new people
onboarded to the code base you need
solid documentation to explain what the
expectations are and how things work
otherwise the code is going to become
very messy very quickly
maintenance it's not the most exciting
thing in the world but systems work
because someone is maintaining them and
keeping them humming along so who who
are these people for your team
is it a centralized setup spread across
different teams what is the skill level
of the people on those teams like how
good are they at the tech stack all this
needs to be taken account into what you
choose for your approach so my
suggestion for decision making is to not
look at the pros or advantages of each
approach because all of them have them
rather you should analyze the cons
analyze the disadvantages to determine
which ones you and your team can accept
and live with and after you've taken all
this time to figure out the approach
there's one more very critical thing to
do before diving into the fun part of
writing the code and you have to
document the why because if you are not
part of the team who built the
application from the start they're going
to be parts of the code base that find
you seem weird or like it's odd why is
this done this way and instead of being
judgmental I strongly suggest asking why
why were things done in this way
sometimes you might find that it was
really just a bad idea right someone put
something up there because they had a
deadline or they didn't know how to do
it better but sometimes you will also
discover that there are some constraints
some or some dependencies or just a
particular situation at that time that
was not obvious to you because you were
new to the code base on the team
so
I know some people don't really want to
update documentation you always hear
comments like oh our application is so
fast it's so fast that the documentation
that I write today is obsolete tomorrow
that's because it's how documentation
why documentation is different a paper
trail that explains why the way things
are is like whiskey it only gets better
with time
so is it possible to use CSS Grid in a
large commercial application
from a technical perspective absolutely
yes
but is there a best way to implement it
well there'll definitely be a best way
for your team to implement it which will
probably be different from the best way
that my team does it because of all
these factors that we've just discussed
so if you ever get the chance to
implement CSS Grid in your project I
want to repeat what hung said yesterday
is that we would love to hear you share
your experience if you can because even
though your approach is specific to your
situation it might still Inspire someone
else who is working on theirs
it comes on my diet
[Applause]